[Musique]
quel bonheur de vous retrouver pour au
bonheur des livres nous allons parler de
la constitution du Conseil
constitutionnel et nous sommes vous le
savez dans cette émission avec Laurent
Fabius monsieur le Président bonjour et
bienvenue dans cette émission avec
Michel cota qui publie chez boulkin ma
5e on en parle beaucoup c'est d' les
livres politiques les plus lus
actuellement le voici ma cher Michel
bonjour et donc avec cette bande
dessinée voulue à la fois par le
président du conseil mais surtout par
Marie Bard vaillante vous êtes
historienne et vous avez collaboré
bonjour à vous avecune dessinatrice pour
essayer de donner une lisibilité à tous
ceux qui vont lire cette bande dessinée
au fonctionnement du Conseil
Constitution
n dans acté extrm Brante à chaque fois
on a l'Impr c'est le conseil qui fait
latique en France le 25 janvier prochain
on aura des décisions qui vous
concernent monsieur le Président
concernant la loi immigration donc voilà
pour la présentation de cette émission
nous sommes dans le fond de la vie
politique française et nous sommes aussi
évidemment dans l'actualité je me
souviens Laurent fabus que lors d'une
des dernières fois que nous sommes
croisés je vous avvez demandé qu'est-ce
que vous aviez eu comme sujet si la
mémoire est bonne à l'oral de normal su
m'aviez dit Michel ser m'avait demandé
quelle est au fond la définition que
vous auriez du héros est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que la politique que
traite Michel et que vous avez vécu
c'est encore le domaine des héros euh il
faut être Fran mon souvenir de ce qui
s'est passé il y a quelques années à mon
oral à normal sub est assez limité mais
ah mais attendez je me suis pas trompé
hein non vous êtes pas trompé et c'est
là où mon amitié a commencé avec Michel
ser et qui depuis malheureusement a
disparu parce que comme il m'avait mis
une bonne note
euh ça lançait bien nos relations non
pour être sérieux je crois que le héros
étymologiquement c'est un demi dieu h
bon est-ce que ce serait la définition
des responsables politiques du monde
entier aujourd'hui n'en suis pas sûr
ouais mais vous savez par exemple
Jean-Luc Barret vient d'écrire un
premier tome sur le général de Gaul
Michel
mais elle a eu le général de Gaulle pour
la 5e il y a quand même cette idée du
héros enfin je veux dire dans dans cette
5e République et la Constitution dont on
va parler on voit bien que ce personnage
de guerre les généraux la rébellion
c'est quand même le statut du héros
Michel ça commençait bien en tout cas
ouais non mais c'est le statut du héros
absolument c'est d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui exp explique qu' après
tant d'années il soit revenu au pouvoir
porter ou incitant lui-même à revenir au
pouvoir enfin c'est vrai que c'était
c'est quelqu'un qui existait mais on ne
l'a plus tellement retrouvé sur la 5e
République après hein h mais vous êtes
formé quand vous dites ça c'est vous
avez l'impression qu'il y a de Gaul et
tous ceux qui ont suivi qui n'ont pas le
même statut que lui qui n'ont pas la
même oui je P le même impact sur la
société je sais pas c'estimpact sur la
société mais ils n'ont pas le même
impact sur l'histoire par définition et
puis pas la même du coup pas le même
impact sur les gens qui sont autour
d'eux sur les relations qu'établissent
les Français avec eux il en a quand plus
haut que d'autres c'est évident euh vous
expliquez d'ailleurs dans le livre que
au fond dans cette attente qu' a ramené
au pouvoir en
58 on a l'impression qu'il y a quand
même beaucoup de ruses et qu'en fait il
s'y attendait que que cet effondrement
auquel vous avez assisté au 2èe
étage de l'Assemblée nationale vous
jeunes journalistes vous aviez 20 ans
vous avez le sentiment quand même que le
général de Gaulle était tapis dans
l'ombre depuis longtemps qu'il avait des
émissaires partout et qu'il attendait
qu'on l'appelle car la 4e allait
s'effondré vrai d'ailleurs oui tout à
fait vrai euh d'ailleurs beaucoup après
me l'ont l'ont raconé après Roger
Stéphane par exemple me racontait il
allait dire au général retournez mon
général on vous attend général ne disait
rien mais prenez un sourire entendu et
puis par rapport aux autres qui lu dis
non vous devriez pas bouger prenez un
sourire moins entendu il y a une grande
partie de rus euh je pense pas qu'il y a
eu un complot mais un complot pour faire
revenir de goou pouvoir mais il y a eu
la partie de ruse de de gaaule
considérable de de gale et de ses amis
politiques et justement une mise en
scène
colossal pour la naissance justement de
cette 5e République ça s passé place de
la République mise en scène d'André
merau donc on pouvait diffic difficement
faire mieux et nous en sommes donc
maintenant à ce Conseil constitutionnel
qui est un conseil qui permet justement
de vérifier chaque jour euh si la loi
est bien respectée dans les vœux que
vous avez prononcé si la loi est bien
respectée si la loi est conforme à la
Constitution qui est la loi des loisou
just absolument mais c'est justement ce
que je voulais introduire à propos des
vœu vous avez prononcé récemment c'est
vous ne voulez pas vous comme président
du Conseil qu'au fond le conseil soit
une sorte de chambre d'écoo de ce qui se
passe à la fois au Parlement ou dans
l'opinion mais que ce soit le lieu du
droit bah c'est la définition le Conseil
constitutionnel qui comprend neu membres
et qui fait l'objet de cette bande
dessinée on va en parler j'imagine euh
il a une tâche bien précise qui est de
vérifier si les lois qui sont votées par
les parlementaires sont conformes ou pas
la Constitution la Constitution c'est la
loi des lois bon il n'a pas d'autres
rôle c'est ça et donc il ne se situe pas
sur le terrain proprement politique il
se situe sur le terrain de la loi il
regarde objectivement impartialement si
la loi est conformme à la cons vous on
vous fait jouer un rôle politique à
partir du moment où le président de la
République vous saisit la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale
oui nous sommes des hommes
indépendants mon prédécesseur et ami
Robert
Badinter donnait une assez jolie
définition de ce que c'est que
l'indépendance que vous ne trouverez pas
dans les manuels de droit il disait
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un homme ou une
femme indépendante c'est quelqu'un qui
n'a rien à redouter et rien à espérer je
trouve que la définition est assez juste
donc nous sommes des juristes on est là
pour ça et contenu en de notre âge et de
notre parcours nous n'avons rien à
redouter rien à espérer donc nous devons
être impartiaux et dire le droit après
pour ce qui concerne la politique il y a
des personnalités qui ont été élu pour
ça qui font leur travail mais nous nous
n'avons pas à entrer là-dedans ou vous
n'entrez pas là-dedans mais les gens
attendent que vous entriez là-dedans
parce qu'au fond non mais les partis
politiques vous le savez il f le travail
il TR attendre cette décision du 25
janvier avec une impatience considérable
oui mais je pense que vous voulez
m'entraîner sur un terrain où je n'irai
pas aujourd'hui bon nous avons été
saisis d'une loi qu'on appelle
immigration nous prendrons notre
décision le 25 janvier c'est la date que
j'ai annoncé sur un certain nombre de
points ou sur l'ensemble du texte bah
nous sommes saisis donc nous répondrons
bien sûr je recommence sur l'ensemble du
texte je
recommence alors là c'est un petit jeu
vous connaissez je su oui bon revenons à
ce qu'est le Conseil constitutionnel le
Conseil constitutionnel a été créé par
De Gaulle bon c'est une novation de la
5e République et ça existe dans toutes
les démocraties avancées c'est-à-dire
que ce sont les parlementaires élu qui
vote la loi très bien bon mais au-dessus
de la loi il y a la loi des lois qui est
la Constitution h et les parlementaires
ils font leur travail mais il faut bien
qu'il y ait un organisme qui vérifie si
oui ou non la loi est conforme à la
Constitution et dans toutes les
démocraties avancées cet organisme c'est
la Cour constitutionnelle
c'est ça notre rôle rien de plus rien de
moins et souvent on nous saisit et à ce
moment-là ou bien nous disons la loi est
tout à fait conforme à la Constitution
pas de problème ou bien nous disons et
bien non il y a un problème parce que la
loi n'est pas conforme à la Constitution
et autre chose je cite à nouveau mon ami
Robert Badinter il n'y a pas de rapport
entre notre décision et la question de
savoir si la loi est bonne et mauvaise
Robert Badinter dit souvent une loi
inconstitutionnelle par définition elle
est mauvaise puiselle est contraire à la
constition mais une loi qu'on peut juger
mauvaise elle peut être très
constitutionnelle et nous notre terrain
c'est c'est conforme ou pas à la cons
c'est le droit voilà euh Marie bardu
valand comment vous avez conçu alors
d'abord vous êtes misise en scène c'est
ça qui est assez amusant dans le
principe de cette BD euh pour écrire
donc dans les couloir du Conseil
constitutionnel car le moins qu'on
puisse dire et c'est vrai et d'ailleurs
c'est aussi d'une certaine manière
relaté par les questions que je posais à
Laurent fabus les gens ont quand même
une connaissance très très approximative
du Conseil constitutionnel du
fonctionnement du Conseil
constitutionnel et des possibilités de
recours qu'on peut avoir soit à titre
collectif soit à titre individuel à
l'égard du Conseil constitutionnel c'est
exactement ce qui m'intéressait en fait
de d'amener au grand public faire œuvre
de pédagogie et de transmission si vous
voulez pour expliquer en fait ce qu'est
cette petite maison parce qu'en fait il
y a pas grand monde dedans et et moiême
pardon combien sont-ils une soixantaine
6 on est tout compris alors il y a neu
membres et puis il y a des
collaborateurs au total nous sommes 70
75 voilà et ce qui est pas énorme parce
que depuis l'extérieur on sait pas tout
ça et et donc dans les couloirs parce
qu'effectivement avec donc la
dessinatrice galie nous avons visité
nous avons pu interviewer interroger
prendre témoignage de toutes les
personnes qui se rappelle que vous êtes
historienne que vous avez déjà écrit
justement sur la politique don c'est
oui oui oui et puis je suis passionnée
par ça voilà c'est vraiment vous parliez
de rert batinter je le connais aussi
j'ai fait une tase dessus donc voilà
c'est c'est c'est vraiment ce sont mes
sujets de fond moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est les mécanismes les détricoter et
de les amener en fait si je fais de la
BD c'est pour ça de les amener au grand
public si vous voulez au public le plus
large possible mais alors justement
puisque nous sommes au bonheur des
livres et qu'il s'agit aussi de parler
de littérature et la BD c'est de la
littérature fondamentalement si vous
deviez expliquer en trois points le
Conseil constitutionnel aux gens qui
nous regardent vous leur diriez quoi
après tout ce travail qui a été fait
alors je dirais déjà que c'est en fait
le la Constitution le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est le cœur de la
démocratie et qu'il faut être vraiment
vigilant par rapport à ça quand il y a
des attaques contre le Conseil
constitutionnel on se rend pas compte à
quel point on attaque la démocratie et
ça c'était vraiment je suis arrivé avec
ça et ça n'a fait que confirmer si vous
voulez avec tout ce que j'ai vu et avec
les personnes voilà avec qui j'ai pu é
changer il y a la question de la QPC que
je trouve vraiment passionnante
n'importe qui il faut redire de quoi il
s'agit la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité donc ben vous demain
Guillaume Durand moi Michel cotta nous
pouvons tous aller si nous estimons
qu'il y a une loi qui qui atteint nos
droits et libertés Michel et moi nous
songons très sérieusement depuis hier
matin je ben vous pouvez alors il y a
toute une démarche avant que ça n'arrive
à la QPC du Conseil constitutionnel si
c'est
validé si c'est validé en tout cas voilà
donc nous on a pu assister à
desqpc on en donne certains exemples
alors c'est c'est alors c'est à la fois
très technique et en même temps c'est
très vaste on peut parler de n'importe
quel sujet donc ça c'était super
intéressant aussi de voir comme ça tout
ce panel qui pouvait être discuté
euh voilà moi pour moi il y avait
vraiment ça le fait que les citoyens
puissent s'emparer en fait de cet espace
là que le Conseil constitutionnel
il nous appartient à tous en fait confme
tout à fait ce que
vient non mais pourquoi moi j'ai
souhaité j'ai fait appel à glena qui a
travaillé complètement librement le
Conseil cons vous l'avez dit l'utre bon
les gens savent que ça existe mais ils
savent pas exactement comment ça
fonctionne et cetera et donc si on veut
et ça c'est ma responsabilité en tant
que président de de cette institution
expliquer au grand public il faut
trouver les mots et les techniques qui
permettent expliquer et notamment pour
le jeune public la BD c'est remarquable
bon et donc les deux autrices ont été en
liberté dans le conseil elles nous ont
accompagné par exemple quand on se
déplace en région puisqu'on tient des
audiences aussi en région elles ont fait
elles ont interviewé qui elles voulent
et cetera elles ont vécu avec nous et
elles disent c'est pour ça que le titre
dans les couloirs du Conseil rend
exactement votre votre travail qui est
un travail libre mais qui est extrêm
informative euh Michel est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment justement que dans le
contexte actuel euh il y a des partis
politiques qui ont l'intention ou qui
aimeraient à l'occasion justement de ce
qui s'est passé pour les retraites ce
qui va se passer sur l'immigration de
faire au fond sauter la 5e République à
laquelle vous consacrez justement cet
ouvrage oui je pense qu'il y a parce que
c'est une question fondamentale parce
que le il est là ex du côté des extrêmes
c'est évident d'ailleurs jean-l chon ne
s'en cache pas il il écrit des livres
là-dessus et sur la la
suppression c'est vrai aussi euh de
Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui mais alors ce
qui est curieux dans la vie politique
c'est que évidemment quand une décision
plaît à l'extrême droite et qu'elle est
critiqué euh par le Conseil
constitutionnelation on est en plein ou
sur l'immigration on est en plein
puisque finalement le rassemblement
national a voté ce que le Sénat avait
voulu et maintenant la gauche veut
absolument que Laurent Fabius et tous
ceux qui travaillent au Conseil
constitutionnel Anil tout ce qui a été
voté par par le Sénat et par peut-être
tous qui a été voté mais enfin une B par
voilà donc ça veut dire que de toute
façon la position du Conseil
constitutionnel est inconfortable
puisque mais elle est très inconfortable
puisquelle seose de temps en temps à la
gauche temps en temps à la droite mais
enfin moi je remarque queun décision du
Conseil constitutionnel n'est pas les
gens
mais après la retraite cétait très
tranquille finalement d'accord mais la
décision est passée ou absolument le
rouleau compresseur il y a quand même un
rouleau compresseur la Constitution dans
le le titre 7 qui est consacré au
consnel dit que nos décisions s'imposent
à tous bon
alors certains selon leurs affinités
peuvent considérer telle décision est
bonne telle décision est mauvaise mais
là nous nous n'avons pas rentré nous
disons le droit ouis mais à craindre
quand même que
certains tendanceend
à à utiliser le droit pour faire de la
politique h ça peut arriver ronard
disait qu'il n'y avait rien de plus
fusitif Laurent fabus que la jeunesse
vous avez été le premier ministre le
plus jeune de la 5e République et
maintenant c'est Gabriel Atal est-ce que
vous considérez que c'est
fondamentalement un bouleversement dans
la société puisque vous l'avez connu ou
est-ce que c'est tout simplement une
volonté d'Emmanuel Macron de sortir
d'une situation compliquée et d'essayer
de rajunir parce que au fond président
mitteran a été avec vous dans la même
situation c'est assez amusant parce que
on m'a très gentiment mis sur mon bureau
deux titres du journal
Libération l'un que j'ai vu récemment le
libération titre je crois
euh monsieur Macron se nomme à Matignon
et ils ont fait exactement le titre le
même titre lorsque moi j'étaéis nommé en
disant mitéron se nomme à matigon donc
bon très
bien le seul commentaire que que je puis
faire euh c'est que il paraît que
jusqu'à la nomination de Monsieur hatal
j'étais recordman de la
jeunesse j'aime beaucoup le sport je
dirais et cette phrase certainement sera
méditée les records sont faits pour être
B voilà très bien et je n'irai pas dans
d'autres commentaires on voit bien que
depuis le début de la 5e République on
on dit toujours que enfin Michel Debray
Premier ministre de de gale racontait
que de Gaul ne s'occupait vraiment que
des choses importantes et que c'est lui
qui tout le reste ça a beaucoup changé
et effectivement on a tendance à
projeter sur le Premier ministre quand
on est président ses volonté et cetera
mais vous disiez Laurent Fabius vous ça
a commencé par vous êtes nommé parmi
Terran mais ça finit par lui c'est lui
et moi c'est moi non euh tout votre
livre est parfaitement exact mais là il
y a une
petite erreur chronologique que font
beaucoup de commentateurs et que vous
connaissez d'ailleurs bon va pas
raconter mon histoire qui est très
distante mais c'est vrai que je suis
nommé j'étais très jeune j'avais été
avant le directeur de cabinet de mitéran
et donc les sondages sont vraiment crève
le plafond et je fais une émission qui
s'appelait l'heure de vérité avec
François vieux et cetera bon et avant de
avant voilà avant de de d'aller à
l'émission j'ai un rendez-vous avec
Françis mitteran don on discute bon on
était très proche très amis et il me dit
comment ça va et cetera je dis écoutez
ça ça va bien CIT au mois de septembre
je crois de 84 donc quelques mois après
avoir été nommé et
euh je dis non ça va bien mais il y a
quand même un problème c'est que les
gens considèrent que je suis encore
votre directeur de cabinet il me dire
oui vous avez raison bon et donc
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire mais dit
je vais à l'émission à l'heure de vérité
et peut-être on pourrait essayer de
trouver une formule pour expliquer que
bien sûr je dire c'est une création
commune attendez attendez j'ai pas je
vous suis très loyal mais enfin j'ai ma
propre personnalité et il était donc
dans son bureau je revois très bien ça
il était moi j'étais de l'autre côté du
bureau il avait son stylo il écrivait
toujours au stylo et est-ce que c'est
lui qui a écrit ou moi qui a écrit on a
conçu ensemble la formule lui c'est lui
moi c'est moi c'est que c'est la
première fois que vous le racontez oui
oui je sais pas
mais bon très bien alors alors oui je
sais
donc arrive l'émission et ça fait partie
des formules improvisées qui ont été
soigneusement préparé je crois que ça ça
n'a pas changé et donc à un moment où
vraiment nous étions tous les deux en
symbiose François Virieux je crois pose
la question et je dis lui c'est lui moi
c'est moi bon ça passe absolument
inaperçu très bien donc c'était TR ou 4
mois après ma nomination ensuite
plusieurs mois plus tard arrivrive
quelques difficultés notamment ce qu'on
appelit la faire jaruselski jaruselski
qui était le président polonais bon qui
était venu en France dans les conditions
difficiles moi j'étais très sensible à
la question des droits de l'homme et
cetera bon on était pas tout à fait sur
la même d' par rapport à François
miteran Bon et donc ça crée une petite
tension et puis après bon la tension et
avec le recul les gens disent mais au
fond Fabius il était il a voulu se
distancier de de miteran puisqu'il a dit
lui c'est lui moi c'est moi mais c'est
pas du tout c'était 6 mois avant voilà
la vérité historique ce qui est très
intéressant dans le travail que vous
avez fait qui en plus était agréable à
lire et cetera bon c'est que vous
expliquez d'une façon que je crois tout
à fait juste quelle est l'évolution de
l'histoire et du rôle du Conseil bon qui
au départ
euh avait été créé par De Gaulle bon
comme un progrès démocratique mais en
même temps à l'époque et je crois pas me
tromper en disant cela et ne pas être
excessif le Conseil était là si jamais
le Parlement n'avait pas agi exactement
comme le voulait l'exécutif euh bon et
bien le Conseil était là pour
sanctionner et puis avec des étapes que
vous expliquez très bien 1971 1974 et
cetera et la QPC le conseil est devenu
une institution indépendante comme les
autres conseils donc euh vous le faites
d'une façon qui est très attrayante mais
en même temps c'est la vérité historique
et au et ça arrive dans beaucoup
d'institutions aujourd'hui le conseil
n'est pas le même que ce qu'il était au
moment de de la création ou parce qu'
une évolution et du conseil
et du milieu politique face au Conseil
oui exactement et le malentendu pardon
avec le grand public qui pense encore
que le Conseil constitutionnel est un
instrument politique vous en parliez
vous-même alors que pas du tout et ça
vraiment B moi je je le savais un peu
mais encore une fois j'en ai eu
confirmation ce que disait le président
Fabius c'est le seul sujet en fait c'est
est-ce que la loi
est en lien avec la constitution ou pas
le reste c'est pas un ça n'a aucune
valeur et euh par exemple sur les
retraites bon ben on peut être en
désaccord et mais il se trouve que qu'on
soit en désaccord ou pas la question
c'est la constitutionnalité en fait de
cette loi làà c'est c'est c'est le seul
c'est le seul débat et le seul sujet
vous prenez aussi l'exemple de de l'IVG
oui oui alors qui va être qui devrait
être constitutionnalisé d'ailleurs
bientôt
donc je voudrais donner les exemples
concernant le livre de Michel je disais
tout à l'heure de Michel cota euh qui
fourmit évidemment d'informations que
vous avez recueilli par exemple
d'abordve Laurent fa vous avez préparé
avec François mitteran le fameux
débat qui est celui
donc l'homme du passé vous avez un peu
tendance à reprendre le refrain d'il a 7
ans l'homme du passé quel dommage que
vous soyez devenu depuis l'homme du
pacif là encore on est dans l'écriture
de quelque chose qui a été prévu puis il
y a une chose que j'adore Michel c'est
quand à un moment de
l'URE interpelle évidemment le président
que va devenir François miteron et qui a
dit lors du débat on va nationaliser
toutes les banques et miteron répond oui
j'ai un petit peu exagéré ce qui prouve
quand même l'extraordinaire légèeté de
la perception qu'il pouvait avoir
j'allais dire du champ
économique je suis pas sûr de ça parce
qu'il savait bien sûr que les
nationalisation allait faire allit poser
problème ne ser ne serait-ce qu'au
patron il il le savait très bien mais
euh il ne voulait à ça prouve qu'il
voulait pas il me semble
j'interprète face au euh jusqu'au
bouhiste qui disait
euh attention euh tout doit être
nationalisé à 100 % et puis face à
l'équipe de Michel Rocard et d'ailleurs
de Delor entre nous qui disait il
vaudrait mieux que ce soit 51 % ça
laisserait ça coûterait moins cher et ça
laisserait tout le monde il v
immédiatement vous voulez dire c'est
l'esprit qui c'est l'esprit des
nationalisations qui marche c'est pas
dans le détail on va pas rentrer en
détail il dit modestement oui j'ai un
peu exagéré de lu dit enfin monsieur le
Président tout de même vous n'êtes pas
allé trop loin oui mais vous décrivez
dans la foulée un M roi Premier ministre
avant Laurent fabus qui lui est est
d'entré très inquiet c'est il a il a le
sentiment que la France va être attaqué
le franc va être attaqué que deor est
déjà aux manettes pour essayer justement
de remonter la p et ça vaevenir
extrêmement compliqué et lorsque Pierre
Mor dit ce jour-là à François mitteran
attention vous savez le Fran la France
s'en va il faut faire quelque chosean
lui dit cétait c'est le jour du Panthéon
où il est couronné au fond par pas
maintenant pierre pas maintenant trouvit
que c'était peut-être pas le moment de
lu poser des problèmes et qu'il voulait
être content tout simplement d'avoir été
élu et je voudrais vous poser une
question à tous les trois sur cette
fameuse 5è publ que vous connaissez par
cœur Michel puisque vous la suivez
depuis le début et que vous avez étudié
madame est-ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'elle est éternelle je veux dire que
c'est la structure de la politique
française pour l'éternité oou est-ce que
à un moment je parle pas du côté
partisan c'est Mélenchon ou Marine Le
Pen qui actuellement veulent peut-être y
mettre un terme mais est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'on sera toujours
dans le même contexte pour des gens qui
ont 15 16 ans aujourd'hui Fabius écoutez
moi j'ai contte tenu de du du parcours
que j'ai fait une
spécificité euh qui est que bon j'ai
dirigé le pouvoir exécutif comme premier
ministre euh j'ai présidé l'assemblée
nationale plusieurs fois et aujourd'hui
je préside le Conseil constitutionnel
donc je vois à peu près comment ça
fonctionne bon et puis j'ai vu comme min
Affaires étrangères les réalités
internationales et je connais les
réalités nationales et aussi locales
puisque j'étais maire donc ça m'a permis
d'avoir quand même certains regards et
alors et
alors je constate d'abord que la
Constitution française c'est celle qui a
la longévité la plus grande de
l'histoire de France bon donc la réponse
est plutôt oui donc et je crois que la
stabilité de ce point de vue-là est un
atout je vous donne un exemple pour ne
pas être long lorsque je discutais avec
mes collègues ministres d'affaires
étrangères h h euh et quand vous
discutez à 5 ou 6 d'un problème
concret si vous savez que le ministre
qui est en face de vous si vous
présentez qui sera plus là dans 3
mois c'est pas lui qui va gagner le
débat si vous savez en revanche qu'il y
aura une stabilité sinon lui du moins de
la ligne politique ou de ça c'est un
atout pour un pays alors ça veut pas
dire que tout est parfait et on ne peut
pas avoir exactement la même pratique
aujourd'hui que il y a 50 ans et en
particulier il y a une volonté de
participation plus grande donc il y a
peut-être des ajustements à faire mais
l'instabilité c'est quand même pour moi
un atout Michel est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que nous sommes partis pour
une éternité de 5e République parce
qu'il y aura un deuxème tome oui ben
enfin oui de mais je veux dire quand
même les ajustements qui ont été
apportés depuis changent la nature de la
5e République alors c'est mieux de faire
ça par petit bout donc de faire évoluer
la Constitution plutôt que de que d'en
changer mais enfin c'est euh c'est vrai
que les le
quinquena change profondément les choses
et est-ce que l'historien a le même
point de vue alors déjà à tytre
personnel moi je crois pas aux éternité
tout simplement euh en revanche oui on
voit qu'elle est stable on voit que
surtout elle peut avoir une certaine
souplesse on peut tout à fait la
critiquer et je personnellement je suis
la première à critiquer il y a quand
même des choses qui sont produites alors
vous parliez du passage du septena au
quinena et moi je suis pas pour hein le
quinkena enfin voilà on va pas ouvrir un
débat là-dessus et autre chose c'est
quand même une constitution qui a permis
de faire rentrer la loi pour l'abolition
la peine de mort justement dedans et ça
c'est assez fondamental pour moi donc on
voit que sur les droits humains sur les
droits et libertés on peut vraiment euh
toucher à des choses qui qui qui qui
sont conséquentes pour nous et qui dans
ce cadre là en plus sont liés quand même
à l'Union européenne donc je dirais
qu'on fonctionne aussi dans dans dans
dans quelque chose de plus vaste si vous
voulez on peut pas c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de parler que de la France
sans voir un petit peu au-delà de ça à
quoi on appartient ce qui est assez
curieux avec vous Laurent fabus c'est
que depuis un certain temps vous peignez
vous écrivez essentiellement sur la
peinture notamment sur les politiques
alors on se dit poliptique oui politique
c'est ce que j'ai dit alors oui oui mais
quand j'ai dit à vous êtes déjà parti
ailleurs
je suis ici euh mais euh c'est vrai que
j'aime beaucoup la peinture bon et que
merm en même temps je mélange pas les
genes aujourd'hui je suis président du
Conseil constitutionnel je ne suis pas
peintre euh mais l'une des raisons pour
lesquel de dans mon dernier livre j'ai
j'ai choisi de ne pas appeler ça
politique mais tableau pluriel c'est que
lorsque je parlait à mes amis euh de
faire un livre sur les polyptiques qui
sont donc les les les les œuvres avec
panneaux multiples ils entendaient
politique il tu vas encore faire la
politique non politique et à ce
moment-là je voyais dans leurs yeux une
espèce
d'interrogation non non il y a des y
quelque part mais combien il y en a-t-il
et où les Méons et donc j'ai préféré
appeler ça tableau pluriel est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment Michel ce sera ma
dernière question que justement les deux
parties qui vont
cinder ce travail sur la 5e République
publié aux édition bouquin sont d'inégal
intérêt c'est-à-dire de l'accession
justement de la 5e République de Gaulle
jusqu'à l'élection de mi-ran et puis
après justement demiterran jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que c'est a
la même intensité non je je pense qu'il
y a une intensit il y a toujours de
l'intensité on a toujours eu des
périodes où bon de 68 qui a été quand
même une grande période qui a pas duré
longtemps mais enfin dans dans dans le
général de Gaulle dans George Pompidou
est sorti victorie
il y a quand même des des moments et les
premiers moments de de François
mitteran président les premiers moments
de que vous racontez d'ailleurs c'est
c'est c'est quand même des après de
Gaulle il y a eu une 5e République qui a
eu autant d'importance que la première
que la première partie je pense merci à
tous les trois d'être venus je rappelle
le livre de Michel cotta qui s'appelle
ma 5e aux éditions bouquin vous
trouverez évidemment des conversations
infil historique important et bien
évidemment le point de vue de Michel sur
la 5e de Michel cota donc sur la 5e
République puisque c'est un livre qui
est à la fois très informé aussi qui est
un livre personnel voulu par Laurent
Fabius mais réalisé donc par Marie
Bardot vaillante et par Gal dans les
couloirs du Conseil
constitutionnel voici donc cette BD qui
est publiée chez glena et qui va vous
permettre de vous informer le mieux
possible sur une institution qui est
fondamental pour justement la 5e
République dont on attend le 25 janvier
des décisions extrêmement importantes
concernant la loi immigration le
président Fabius n'a pas voulu en dire
plus je ne peux pas le torturer donc
nous allons passer à une émission
suivante la semaine prochaine merci à
tous les trois d'être venus merci à vous
j'ai été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ravi